it's the last day of rallies for kenya's
presidential candidates
[Music]
and the campaigns are in full force
deputy president william ruto may be
behind in the pulse but his hustler
platform has young people singing his
praises
[Applause]
like these guys here
dancing like die hard supporters
but are they
what do you guys do
especially
hustlers
yeah so are you being paid to attend
this rally
yeah we get paid how much
range from 500 shieldings that around
five dollars to
ten dollars
high unemployment and living costs has
many kenyans finding creative ways to
make ends meet i mean we were just with
these guys at the ruto rally where they
were singing and dancing it was very
believable and now you've put on blue
white
red odinga rally colors and you're going
over to his side to campaign for him
i mean this is why it's so difficult to
know who's going to win this race
we follow them across nairobi to the
campaign finale of former prime minister
and front-runner ryla odinga so how much
were you guys paid to attend this rally
i dingus rally uh
1500 1500 yeah 1500 that's 15
so even though you're being paid to come
here you guys are you going to be voting
on tuesday
yes yeah
that's a that's a democratic right you
have to practice
are a lot of other people here being
paid as well yeah
so then how do you know who actually
wants him to win and who's just here for
the money
okay you see um money is something that
every everybody wants
and when you are giving money you won't
refuse to take it
but at the end of the day you know where
your passion is
where your vote lies
this is odinga's fifth time running for
the presidency and it's anyone's guess
how his supporters will react if he's
unsuccessful
what guarantees do we have that your
supporters will remain peaceful if you
don't win this election
of course my brothers supporters are
always peaceful
but in 2007 at least a thousand people
were killed when you lost the election
but that was because the elections were
rigged
my people were
dissatisfied
they were not the ones who actually was
the violence
appreciate your time thank you
[Music]
wait wait wait wait calm down
despite his assurances there's no
certainty that calm will prevail come
next week
sky news nairobi